what's a bad show for you like when you
sit there and you're in a bad mood the
next day is it that the monologue was
flat no I think a bad show for me is one
I think where we where we've just made
it what I consider to be a talk show
that anybody could do but some of those
are the ones where I'll go well anyone
could have done that right anybody could
have run anybody could have read those
jokes done that death bit ask those
questions introduce that band and said
good night anybody could have done that
and the ones that I love are the ones
where I go no no that's that's that's
what we can that's what we can do that's
what we're capable of of whether it's
big song huge taped bit out carp or
whatever big sketch you know Chat Chat
music things like I didn't think you've
eels alive you know cuz you said you
view your show is a variety show and I
get that for sure you're not trying to
do a talk show no you're trying to say
hey if I get a guest in there I want to
do maybe we do a song maybe we do
carpool karaoke maybe we sit there and
eat disgusting things like cow tongue or
whether it's a sketch maybe we have a
thing where somebody comes in and
interrupts the show and no one knew that
they were coming maybe somebody else
walks out and starts the monologue what
is the way that we can make it feel like
it's absolutely alive you know yeah and
that's a lot of that's because we're on
after a talk show you know what I mean
like I like that you know you've got to
try and always sit at the other side of
the seesaw I think of what you're doing
do you not I mean and that's the way we
can also um I don't ever consider myself
a broadcaster I consider myself a
performer really yeah so you are yeah I
think I think that's probably where my
strengths lie so lots of people would
say about these shows they guys go play
to your strengths and I say no I think
you just could have ignore your wits
it's